[Music]
you're in the Angry Birds movies yeah
right yeah that is true your voices I
mean it's animated but yeah but yeah I
play it I didn't think you were in a
bird costume well you never know you
know I mean you know you don't think I
have that range no I do
amazing I apologize so you're in the
Angry Bird John movie is that what do
you look at that is it it it like to me
I don't know any better because I don't
do voiceover work and he's actually done
quite a bit of work you do voiceover
work I not anymore since the accident eh
yeah yeah yeah bad yeah yeah yeah I
frankly don't even know why I'm here
yeah he said he was sick and he didn't
want to come in and I said you coming in
no gotta sweep up yeah
no no I I'm just curious about whatever
the hell we were talking about the boys
there you go I'm sorry stuff it's so
much harder than then people than I
would ever realize now out of respect to
people that build bridges and teach
teenagers that don't want to be there
it's relatively you know not that
difficult but like it's more strenuous
every time I do it it'll be like five
hour chunks and then I leave and then
the next day I feel probably like how
you're feeling now and I'm sore like my
diaphragm sore somehow like you're like
which part is the hardest part you think
of doing voiceover work for an animated
film I would say towards the end they
always do they do a thing and we were
just talking about could we just start
doing press for and like Bill hader's in
the movie and Danny McBride and Josh GAD
like it's a good fun group of guys and
we're sort of talking about it like it's
the they call it the efforts when like
so if you've gone through an entire
movie like you know three acts and this
one's like an action-adventure kind of
storyline you know there's catapults and
TNT no spoilers you've played the game
but then you just have to do just random
up okay we want you to sound like you're
falling down a tree and hitting every
branch all right you do that for like a
minute straight then like okay now do it
but the tree branches are actually a
little bit bigger so you're like
[Laughter]
exactly my god you guys cheering me on
after everytime it no it's just another
guy going okay great let's do it again
and here's it was like no love you know
I mean yeah they said an ab workout
gotta go look at like the checking
account to be like okay yeah let's go do
this again alright here we go
but it's and then you're always my
throat's like I've been you know going
back and forth on a plane with a bunch
of like sick runny nose four-year-olds
yeah like touching my face I feel awful
the next day but you know it's pretty
fun out regardless yeah at the other day
yes it's better it's better than like
you know a lot of things
you